the fundamental problem of large
economies is how do we coordinate
Behavior amongst each other and it's
useful to have these Central nodes these
coordinating mechanisms the problem is
that the power becomes concentrated and
uh and for this reason I I thought you
know the evolution of something like
Bitcoin for example I mean this is kind
of good I mean this is the threat of
this is going to force some governments
to kind of perhaps you know if if
concerned governments are abusing their
power of the inflation tax you know this
is different than just the US dollar now
any kid with a cell phone can download
an app and like start exchanging in
Bitcoin and it's going to be very hard
for the state to kind of ban this
activity or enforce bans that this might
serve as a as a useful way to discipline
uh governments
all right guys bang bang I've got David
here with me David you were the very
first Central Banker in the world to
give a public presentation on bitcoin
which will make you very popular with
our audience but I thought a great place
to start the conversation is just how
did you come across this weird
decentralized digital currency while
working at a central bank yeah I think
my earliest recollection is reading I
think an op-ed piece by uh Paul Krugman
in fact where he was uh highly critical
of the Endeavor uh and and that got me
to uh dig into the uh into Bitcoin to
see what he was talking about and
initially I I have to say I shared
krugman's skepticism but uh
um after after uh opening the hood so to
speak and digging into it I found that
it was something really really quite
interesting so you wrote a blog post I
think in 2013 and then you followed it
up and you went on a tear in 2014 you
did like five presentations or blog
posts and you were kind of really
exploring it and I think giving what I
would call a good faith effort based on
some of the presentations and what I
appreciate about in hindsight looking at
that stuff is you were uh complimentary
in certain cases you questioned certain
things and said look I don't know if we
have an answer for this yet and then you
were critical in other cases and so in
order to understand Bitcoin I think we
got to kind of go back and look at it
from the view of you know what is the
role of money what's the role of the
Central Bank and so given that you
worked inside of these organizations one
thing that you hit on over and over and
over again where I think you were
comparing Bitcoin the dollar gold and
other assets is this idea of money
having to be stable in short periods of
time correct talk a little bit as to why
is that so important in your mind yeah
that's it's a it's a bit of a subtle
point right I mean uh that for what's
important for a monetary instrument I
think and I think most monetary thieves
would agree is is the short run
stability of its value you need to meet
payroll by Friday say it's Monday you
need to meet payroll by Friday you want
to uh that payroll is a fixed amount of
whatever it could be X number of dollars
or Bitcoin or whatever you you want to
be sure that that that that that that
that that money is is there and worth
what it's worth on Friday and you're
will you know if inflation is running at
five percent I mean ten percent I mean
you're going to lose a little bit in
purchasing power but not that much
um what's more important for you uh to
manage cash flow is the short run
stability of the monetary instrument
um ideally I mean uh you don't want to
lose over the long run as well but uh
there are certain trade-offs and so I've
argued that for example gold and Bitcoin
uh are not really well suited uh to
serve this role just because uh their
demands can be very volatile in the
purchasing power can fluctuate over very
short periods of time making managing
payments very difficult
um that's not to say that gold and
Bitcoin might not be good as long run
stores of value are great hedges in some
cases so I try to make that distinction
and see how so you basically are pulling
out okay there's this like long run uh
what historically so far has been a
appreciate creation of purchasing power
with gold and Bitcoin dollar and other
Fiat currencies have lost purchasing
power over the long run but I think you
highlighted this short run stability and
use the example of you know if it's
Monday and you got to make payroll on
Friday uh there's a fixed kind of debt
if you will right or a fixed amount that
you've got to pay and if your money is
worth two times that on Monday it's
worth fifty percent of that on Tuesday
on Wednesday it's worth you know 150
percent and it's kind of fluctuating you
almost don't know if you're gonna have
the money on Friday to be able to pay it
it sounds like there's two solutions
that I would highlight one which I think
is kind of what you're getting at which
is like you have short run stability of
the assets purchasing power so that
whatever you have to pay on Friday you
have that and it doesn't change
throughout the week the second would be
to actually have uh a similar unit of
account so if I'm holding Bitcoin but I
have to pay in dollars the US Dollar
exchange price is obviously super
volatile right of Bitcoin I use super as
it could fluctuate five percent in a day
ten percent whatever
but if I have my payroll in the unit of
account of Bitcoin and I have Bitcoin
does that take away the short-term
volatility risk yes a little bit because
you eliminate the exchange rate risk
that's inherent in any uh you know um
when you have for example obligations to
nominate in some foreign currency
deposure in in uh uh South America and
you denominate that in U.S dollars
you're subject yourself to exchange rate
fluctuations what you're talking about
is Imagine now however uh Society where
say Bitcoin or gold is actually the unit
of account
um and and that does mitigate a little
bit the uh that problem but not entirely
um and you know we've had kind of
quasi-experiments of this sort in the
past uh gold standards for example where
um where
um you know what again what we witnessed
was
especially during times of Crisis what
you see is a this kind of flight to
safety phenomenon where people just rush
into the safe asset this case gold or
Bitcoin and the effect of this is to
dramatically uh increase the the price
of Bitcoin relative to Goods uh and and
so again uh you know producers
um or or
um you know workers who are uh you know
being paid in this object uh are have
their debts denominated in a nominal
Bitcoin let's say let's say I you owe
um a thousand Bitcoin but suddenly
there's this increase in the demand for
Bitcoin because people are freaking out
and that drives the purchasing power of
Bitcoin you know doubles it uh you're
gonna have to work a lot harder to
discharge that Bitcoin debt now uh
because the purchasing power of your
labor now is much lower so
that is the argument that uh you know it
doesn't that argument uh letting the
Bitcoin or the gold or this hard money
be the uh unit of account does not
entirely eliminate the problem uh that
I'm highlighting here so dollars I think
for most people they would agree it
solves the short-term volatility problem
if I owe you know a thousand dollars on
Friday it's Monday if I have a thousand
dollars I'm likely to still have that
same thousand dollars that I can pay
correct does the same uh kind of issue
get solved even though the dollar gets
depreciated over time so when you talk
about you know kind of hard money
appreciating and having to work harder
right because the purchase power is
increasing what is the impact when the
dollar is actually uh losing value let's
say if there was a massive quantitative
easing or something like that where the
purchase power was eroded well you mean
during a time of Crisis correct well I
mean in fact you know the Fed was
founded in 1913 precisely I think the
language actually says to provide an
elastic currency that is to say uh
during a crisis what happened and since
there's a tremendous flight to safety
and that that flight to safety asset can
vary over times but in recent times it's
been the US dollar and U.S treasury
um and and look uh if if there had been
performed the hypothetical back in 2008
let's say the financial crisis and let's
try to imagine that the FED did not
engage in quantitative easing that the
treasury that the government did not run
those very large deficits supplying the
the U.S treasuries that the global
economy was demanding uh I conjecture
that we would have witnessed the mother
of all deflations we we saw interest
rates on T belts go negative people were
so so in need are desirous of places to
store their money in a safe place and
there's not many safe places you can go
um and so
I think that um it's it's usual to think
about that counterfactual
um
this is the short run right this is the
whole point of of the elastic currencies
is to supply the currency that's
demanded in the short run to alleviate
the elevated demand but then at the same
time once that elevated demand has
dissipated
to then contract the currency I think a
lot of Skeptics are are always uh but
they're critical of is that that second
part doesn't seem to come to play and so
ultimately this manifests itself as a
lower purchasing power for the currency
going forward and that's that's kind of
a legitimate criticism but again
conceptually we have to separate out
these you know short run versus long
time term uh stabilized value of the
monetary object so when you talk about
short run versus long run does is it
possible for one asset to serve both
cases or is it a classic trade-off of if
you want something that's stable in the
short term and you want to use this kind
of elastic monetary policy or variable
monetary policy to address short-term
issues you have to just understand the
trade-off is long term you're likely to
have issues or is there an example of an
asset that's been able to Surf both over
history I think that um the US dollar
could in principle serve both purposes
for example that it would depend
um it would depend on the following for
example Congress could pla make an
amendment to the Federal Reserve Act
which is the act that established the
FED in 1913 our elected representatives
in in currency could mandate that the
FED follows a hard money policy over the
long run they can do that so in
principle it's possible as a practical
matter I don't think it's going to
happen for a variety of reasons but I
think it is possible for
um you know these elastic currency to
operate certainly I can show it
mathematically the question is really
boils down to political
um I don't think Bitcoin can do it
because uh its protocol is it's a hard
money protocol I'm not criticizing that
I'm just describing the the supplies
essentially fixed or grows on a fixed
schedule
um conceivably there might be other
protocols I do know that there has been
experimentation of cryptocurrencies that
do provide that elastic currency
function and you could kind of program
the elasticity be in along with the hard
money uh policy into the code I think
that's conceivable and I do think people
have tried to work on that
I'm not so sure how successful they've
been yet yeah people are going to try it
for sure
take me inside the room at a central
bank during whether it's a moment of
Crisis or kind of these short-term uh
decisions right I think from the outside
uh the average American don't even know
the Central Bank exists right they're
just like hey I'm going to work I'm
going to make money I'm gonna go home do
my thing and I just want to live my life
and like what's a central bank right uh
for those that are a little bit more uh
maybe knowledgeable or interested uh
their view is that there are people who
go into a basically a conference room
there's a bunch of data that's presented
and kind of consumed uh and there's some
I call it guesstimating right in terms
of okay we're looking at data I think
the Central Bank knows that the data is
probably a little bit uh lacking in
terms of you know immediacy uh it's not
real-time data uh and then two is I
think every Central Banker I've ever
talked to is like very well aware of the
complexity and difficulty of trying to
use you know data that happened 60 days
ago to make a decision today to try to
forecast what's going to happen in the
future but was that your experience like
what happens in those rooms well gosh
those rooms I mean so I I was a senior
vice president to St Louis Fed so the St
Louis fed is one of 12 Regional feds in
the Federal Reserve System and that is
centered at the Board of Governors in
Washington DC
um in times of Crisis I have to say it's
really the Board of Governors in D.C
along with treasury the administration
that kind of you know take hold the the
regional fed presidents uh typically
play a more important role in the
day-to-day conduct of monetary policy in
the uh eight Federal open market
committees the fomc meetings that are
held each year but here let me walk you
through what happens I'm working there
you know I'm an advisor to Jim Bullard
uh Jim Bullard has there's a board of
directors in fact the board of directors
uh is what appoints the president of the
regional feds uh these board of
directors are Bankers Regional they're
local banks they're people from the
community they could be uh they're not
just Bankers but business people
um and and social workers it could be a
wide variety of people on this board
um and the president meets them on with
them on a regular basis and they report
on their business what's going on what's
going on with the regional Banks you
know what's going on with my business
what am I seeing and and so the FED
precedent gets a lot of first-hand
reports from his board members
that President also has a lot of
contacts in the region I think Walmart
is headquartered in the uh in the St
Louis District so you're talking to the
CEO of Walmart tell me you don't get
information about what's happening in
real time we're talking to the CEO of
Walmart he gets a lot of information on
top of this we have in St Louis and
other branches but in St Louis we have
three regional branches one in
Louisville one in Little Rock and one in
Memphis they each have board of
directors populated Again by local
representatives of the community you
know I've been down there you talk to
them they have go-arounds they report on
their business they report what's
happening around the uh the local
economy uh the FED president uh gets all
this information and then he's briefed
by his staff myself for example we have
regular fomc briefings uh and then
there's Council uh we a small group of
us will meet with a president and and
kind of disseminate and all our or
process all this information and think
of about uh very what it might apply for
say interest rate policy at the upcoming
meeting then they all gather at the fomc
eight times a year all of them in this
room along with their assistance and a
few other people in the room and they
discuss they have an economic go around
where each fed president and every board
member reports on local conditions uh
especially the FED Regional feds are
reporting on San Francisco Federal
report on the Western District Etc New
York fed Etc
they have an economic go around and then
they have uh the next they have a
discussion about what the appropriate
policy action is so yeah there you go I
mean that's just a a a little bit of uh
um you know there's a lot of stuff going
on I mean it's not perfect but I think
that they're uh the FED presidents the
fomc the ones who are undertaking the uh
monetary policy decisions are are about
as well informed as anyone in New York
fed in particular will have direct a lot
of information on Wall Street and what's
happening in financial markets so I I
think they're about as well prepared as
anybody in terms of the information they
have about available so I've gone
through probably too much of the data in
terms of people have asked me questions
over the years I'm like I don't know the
answer let me go and read documents or
or figure it out I I think there's three
parts maybe that'd be interesting to get
your perspective on the first is what
I'll call uh kind of CPI calculation
right and so
um it's changed over time uh I think
that every person I've ever talked to
that's been involved in trying to figure
out how do we measure inflation
essentially
super good nature trying to do it it is
very difficult to do and they will even
go as far as to say look there's like 10
different ways we couldn't do it what
we're trying to get at is a specific way
to measure it so that it can be used as
part of monetary policy help inform the
the general public help inform business
owners Etc and so it's not just you know
measuring only one way because that's
the only way to do it it's actually no
we know multiple ways to do this what is
the right way to do it for what we're
trying to accomplish I think it's an
important kind of call out and so as I
kind of went through this one of the
things that surprised me is there's a
couple hundred people who physically go
into stores right and they're and
they're manually inputting the data and
the part that you know kind of is the
headline grabbing part is uh somebody
one time went and they said I talked to
that person I interviewed them and they
got you know eight page print out of
exactly like the Campbell Soup low
sodium whatever to make sure they got
the right one and you start to realize
like again there's the theory but then
in practice like if you send someone to
the store and you say hey go get the
price for X good well take just soup
alone right it there could be Campbell
Soup there could be other brands there
could be low sodium high sodium like
there's all these things
when you compare that to you know maybe
in the real estate market we have Zillow
an apartment.com and these guys they
have data that data tends to be what
they claim to be real time I don't know
you know kind of how real time and
sometimes these data points match right
kind of the uh Bureau of Labor
Statistics and and these private
companies sometimes they don't
does the Central Bank look at the
private company data sets do those
companies give them the data or is it
pretty much what we see with like the
BLS and the CPI calculations like that's
what they're using as well yeah that's
it's a good question I'll tell you
honestly I don't know exactly I've never
myself personally got into the details
of actually uh collecting the data of
course I along with most economists are
aware of all the pitfalls that you
describe
um
um for for your listeners by the way
there's this thing out there called a
million prices project I don't know if
you've heard of that I mean this is a
private Endeavor to calculate the cost
of living these price indices and I'll
just have to say what they come up with
doesn't look a lot different than what
you see from the official statistics
um the recent episodes a little bit
different because the real estate the
the manner in which uh owner occupied
rent and enters into the CPI how it's
calculated I think there's a general
recognition that gosh we need to do a
better job here uh and availing
themselves still like Zillow the
real-time data data that's that's uh
potentially available I think would be
an excellent idea I'd be surprised if
they they aren't trying to trying to do
it I I can't report to you exactly and
say that they are but I would be very
surprised if they're not they're always
looking for ways to improve and to get
the measurements uh right and and you're
right we I know that the FED doesn't
just look at one measure I mean I know
that they have the official measures the
pce headline measure but they look at
they look at all sorts of measures and
and one of the nice things is is that
most of the measures you look at look at
are essentially most of the time telling
you the same thing and you can't really
fine-tune things too much in terms of
policy you kind of really have to try to
identify Trends I believe and and and
and these indices do do I think at least
give us that but I would be all in favor
of using whatever high frequency data is
at our disposal to improve the methods
for sure yeah it's because I've sort of
CPI uh there's you know core and kind of
all these other official metrics uh you
mentioned the million prices project I
think uh historically people on Twitter
have loved to go to Shadow stats which
there's questions around you know kind
of the accuracy of that
um there's a new measurement called
trueflation right that is trying to get
at uh using on-chain data and so I I do
think
um you know in the United States we've
been very fortunate that we've actually
uh most people uh have lived through low
inflation environments right and so
unless you were kind of really locked in
and paying attention uh kind of uh um
you know in the 80s or so then you never
thought about it right so for 40 years
or so we've lived in this low inflation
environment now compared to some other
countries around the world this is you
know one of the most important things to
them they really understand inflation
and currencies and things like that but
over the last three years now all of a
sudden people kind of poke their head up
and say hey hold on a second let me let
me learn more about this inflation thing
and so naturally that leads us some of
them saying well maybe I could measure
it better which is you know again
interesting I don't know if they can or
can but
it feels like having more data points
available is better for the people
making the decisions right absolutely
and and I I do think that they you know
like I said I'd be surprised if there
aren't people working very hard to to
incorporate that information
so one of the other pieces of this is uh
once the central bank is kind of
consuming all of that data there is a
human decision-making process right it's
not formulaic in the sense of uh one
plus one equals two and no matter what
anyone says one plus one equals two and
that's what we're going to do right it
is very much as you described uh the
intake of information the synthesization
of that information and then a human is
making that decision one of the things
that attracted me to bitcoin was this
idea of like an automated central bank
right which like now with the rise of AI
everyone's like oh is my job going
to get automated but it's this idea that
like bitcoin's not consuming any
information right so it's kind of
alleviated itself from that
responsibility and instead it's just
saying look we are going to have a
pre-programmed you know kind of
programmatic monetary policy I don't
care what happens in the world like
we're going to operate on this maybe
that's better maybe it's not right you
can no Pine on that but the idea that
there's no humans participating is
fascinating to me because I don't trust
my friend to give me a suggestion I go
to Google right I don't trust my friend
to give me directions somewhere I go to
Google Maps
um and so it doesn't beg this question
of like you know should we just dump all
the data into some kind of formula or
some uh kind of computer program and
rather than the individuals themselves
making the decisions like could the
software do it better I don't know what
do you think well I mean uh truth be
told I mean uh in our economic models
when we write down policy functions that
are go by these names like the Taylor
rule if any of your uh listeners are
familiar with that you can Google it I
mean if Taylor rule is basically a
formula a mathematical formula that uh
purportedly describes the in qualitative
manner the manner in which interest rate
policy is set High inflation tends to
elicit rate increases a weak economy
tends to elicit rate cuts and so in our
economic models they take exactly that
form I want to push back a little bit
though here in saying that uh um it's
it's not like a Bitcoin is completely
divorced from a human interaction it was
a human who designed the protocols I I
kind of view it more like the
Constitution a legal framework a set of
rules that govern uh the way certain
things are done I was a human humans
designed these things and indeed uh it's
not as if Bitcoin is not alterable I
mean in principle I mean in fact I my
understanding is early on
um you know certain bugs were fixed by
Patches by the core developers I mean
it's it's like you you want the
community actually to fix things that go
wrong it would be bad to have errors and
not Constitutional Amendments I mean
these are you know we need we humans
player still have player role there but
I understand what you mean it's like
okay once we've got kind of the right
you know I don't know it's like a human
designed a car but now we can program it
to drive and we just let the car uh
bring in data and it can navigate itself
on its own without error
um I think that's a really interesting
idea I wonder how far we can push it
um
uh in in our models I mean what happens
in our models in our mathematical models
and I I uh and and listeners I mean we
all have models
of the way the world Works embedded in
our heads yes uh they're not as well
formulated or as as or explicit
mathematical models but they're there
and nevertheless
um we're going to design something
relative to solving a problem that uh
according to the way the world works in
the model we have in our head well you
better be damn sure that you got the
right model how can you be so sure I
mean that world is a very complicated
things it's been my experiences that you
write down something that is a great uh
solution to particular environment but
that environment you didn't account for
X Y or Z the unknown then what do you do
you need some discretion you need
somebody with wisdom you need somebody
you can trust you can you need somebody
to accommodate those unforeseen events
you can't I don't think program every
contingency into this model
uh at least not yet I mean I I think if
you could you'd basically be God yeah
we're not there what you're highlighting
is actually uh not not something that I
think is too far outside of the world of
Finance I mean George Soros this is
basically his like philosophical view of
the world right it's this idea of like
imperfect understanding and he really
hammers on the idea that like even
though you could look at a set of facts
you cannot simply uh evaluate just the
facts you also have to evaluate how will
people perceive those facts and what
actions will they take which will then
influence the environment and the
situation and so
um you know he kind of separates out
somebody who is uh kind of evaluating or
thinking about it versus somebody who's
participating in the environment so even
the model itself if it doesn't account
for what the model is going to do you
kind of get into this very you know uh
Meadow world if you will of the model's
impact actually has to be programmed
into the model also no that's absolutely
correct I mean we we're fond of saying
in economics and I think in social
science in general that the data does
not speak for itself
I mean let me repeat that the data does
not speak for itself it's impossible you
need an interpretive framework a model a
way to organize your thinking this is
what we all have in our brains it's
nothing to be ashamed of it's It's we we
try to do the best we can all of us uh
every every day and this includes policy
makers at the fomc they're not
infallible uh but hopefully you know we
learn and these institutions evolve in a
way that helps serve uh the broader
Community but exactly you're right on
point so I want to go before we talk
about the first presentation that you
did publicly I want to talk about the
blog post of the euro in 2013. you wrote
uh it was titled why golden Bitcoin make
lousy money and uh we talked a little
bit already about this desirable
property of monetary instrument is that
it holds its value over short periods of
time right but you later said it is
important for a monetary instrument to
hold its value over long periods of time
I'm sorry is it important for a monetary
instrument to hold its value over a long
period of time I used to think so but
now I'm not so sure
and so I thought that was very
interesting because you basically are
saying look one you're changing your
mind a little bit right which as you
kind of think more about this stuff
hopefully you do change your mind you
would be a a Bonafide genius if you got
it right on the first try but talk a
little bit as to how you view the
long-term uh sustainability of
purchasing power for money and the
importance of that or the lack thereof
yeah you know so so early on I mean my
my initial thinking uh was you know I
mean why on Earth would you want the
monetary unit to depreciate in value
over time I mean I it's a it's a metric
it's the way we measure things why I we
don't change uh the length of a yard the
length of a yard or a meter uh depending
on your audience here I mean this we
don't change it over time a meter
doesn't shrink and and there's a great
deal of utility uh in principle of
having a metric that retains you know
that remains stable over time so ideally
uh why not just a constant price level
this permits relative prices that change
the price of apples relative to oranges
can change but the overall price level
should remain remain fixed over time
this is kind of how I thought and
there's still a lot of Merit to that
argument
um I guess uh over time though I mean it
kind of I I come to appreciate a kind of
practical matters I mean uh you know our
elected representatives
uh you know are are at the power to tax
and to to do whatever I mean this is uh
to make transfers the fund
infrastructure uh the interstate highway
system NASA whatever and and
um they they typically Finance
um you know these Endeavors through
taxation and and we we we submit to it
implicit either explicitly at The Ballot
Box or implicitly it's part of uh part
of our our contract of of uh you know
Civil Society now if the government has
to tax and I don't know a lot of your re
listeners might shut off right now but I
mean suppose that they have to tax the
question is you know how do you do it we
have income tax wealth tax consumption
tax
inflation tax I mean why should the
inflation tax not be a part of that uh
mix this is especially the case in fact
in developing economies I don't have
well-developed tax collection systems
how do you fund a public school or
public roads in an economy that doesn't
have a well uh you know it's very
difficult to collect taxes and yet in
principle there's a public project that
needs to be financed you know what I'm
not going to be such a hard ass to say I
want a stable price at all costs I can
kind of see the Merit of increasing the
money supply to hire a few construction
workers to clear the road and build a
school and to grow some corn and feed
the kids and give them free lunch I I
don't know if that's going to cost me
one percent for a year my purchasing
power I mean the government could tax me
directly through my income tax or my
wealth facts land tax if they do it
instead by uh increasing the money
supply and financing it in that manner I
can kind of see well you know as long as
as long as the monetary unit maintains a
stable short run value as I say I mean
it's still still serve its purpose to
facilitate payments uh and okay it loses
a little bit of its value I just
consider that a part of a tax what I
don't like it go in and and call your
congressperson your elected
representative and rail against it but
in the grand scheme of things if I see
two three four percent inflation I'm not
going to get terribly excited I don't
necessarily like it but I mean it's yeah
I can see how that that's how my
thinking kind of evolved along that
Dimension so this is interesting because
I think
um a lot of people don't think that way
right and don't see it as a tax
obviously uh for those that do uh I've
seen two different groups uh respond one
is uh I think kind of your Camp right
which is uh okay I might not like it I
understand it
um and if it's one or two percent it's
not 20 or you know Argentina 100 or
whatever it is uh at the moment there's
another camp that goes wait a minute we
fought Wars like you know uh no taxation
without representation like oh we didn't
elect these people we didn't uh you know
subscribe to that monetary policy
whatever how do you kind of balance out
what I'll call like the explicit
taxation right which is uh always seems
to be going up over the long run right
never never seems to kind of come down
uh although there are short-term tax
cuts
um versus this more like implicit type
taxation
because
it has the effect of attacks but it is
not explicitly a tax and so how do you
think about that from like uh the
intersection with politics and kind of
representation yeah it's a very good
idea and by the ways I just I I want to
mention too even if inflation is two
percent three percent it's not like
people do not save their money in cash
they save the money like right now
interest rates are five percent on T
bells and stuff so
we we uh we only save a very small
fraction of our wealth and zero
interest-bearing security so for again
that that tax is I it's not something
that would I go crazy about
but good point you know I mean people
have brought this up I mean at least
um you know in a gold standard regime or
a hard money regime uh if the government
wanted to finance something it would
have to go through the legislative
process explicitly and kind of vote you
know uh and and and so taxation with
representation
um the way I can reconcile this is you
know the the Federal Reserve uh first of
all the treasury is part of the
government
secretary uh Janet Yellen is part of the
administration uh the administration we
we elected uh the president
so uh you know she's operating under the
under uh the guidance of an unelected
official
um the Federal Reserve itself was
established by uh Congress in in 1913
there's a Federal Reserve Act it
prescribes
um the fed's mandates and the available
tools of the Fed
um and uh the Federal Reserve chair is
required twice a year to testify in
front of Congress once in front of
Senate once in front of the house and he
takes uh he or she takes some very very
difficult questions so there's some
accountability in in that sense even
though the the Board of Governors are
they're appointed by POTUS
ratified by the Senate there's some
representation there the FED president's
a different matter they're they're
elected by by Boards uh
but at the end of the day I would say
that there is at least an implicit uh um
um you know representation there the
sense that although the FED fed
officials are technocrats uh uh that at
least uh you know they they are
accountable to elected representatives
and it is within the power of the
American people
the pressure they are elected
representative
to modify the monetary policy in the way
they see fit again if you do not like
inflation even at two percent if you
want zero percent Lobby or congress uh
many are representative and get them to
change the Federal Reserve Act that
restricts the FED in that manner you I
you're not necessarily going to like the
outcome let me tell you but I mean you
can do it
like let's just say uh can I play off
that hypothetical right so somebody
calls up the Congress person and they
say hey yeah I don't like this
um and enough Americans do it where
Congress says oh maybe we need to pay
attention to this
um and Congress decides that they're
going to make a change does change
change the Federal Reserve Act does it
uh remove current officials at the FED
like what do you what do you think is
within the
um maybe kind of uh mandate or or within
the tools that Congress then would you
know use if they thought the American
people uh really did want to change and
they wanted to represent the American
people in that sense well I mean like I
said they could explicitly uh be more
specific about what they mean by Price
stability so the Federal Reserve Act
does uh you know one of the Prime
mandates of the FED is uh price
stability and and and and more recently
full employment uh these are are kind of
notoriously difficult to Define
especially full employment but price
stability has recently been interpreted
by central banks around the world as low
uh and stable inflation uh two percent
per year as measured by PC
you can I mean you can change that you
can say no I'm sorry we're going to have
it like zero percent I mean you could
actually do that and then uh we're gonna
give you the tools uh to achieve that
mandate I mean that could be done in
principle
the fact that it isn't done suggests to
me that you know this is there's a lot
of problems in the world and and uh the
FED has been relatively successful I
would argue I'm sorry people out there
it's a very complicated world out there
it's very difficult the FED has limited
tools by the way but if you take a look
at the history of inflation in the
United States to say since the volcker
era we've by and large had low and
stable inflation you said yourself
people aren't you weren't even paying
attention to inflation until recently
and the recent about I mean I have a
very good explanation for what happened
and it starts with coved uh but by and
large you know relative to other
countries and relative to uh other
periods in history it it hasn't been too
bad surely there are bigger fish to fry
I would say but so one of the things
that
um I hear a lot in the Bitcoin community
and I think is a fairly valid argument
is uh you mentioned earlier that most
people don't keep uh their money in you
know zero interest uh type assets right
and so cash uh ends up being a thing I
think that's true for business people
people in finance uh people who
um understand some of these problems pay
attention things like that I went and I
looked one time at the percentage of
Americans who have no Investments so
whether they're living paycheck to
paycheck or they could be making
millions of dollars a year they just
stick it all in cash right and it blew
me away it was 50 yeah now maybe that
number is off let's call ten percent
either direction but it's a big number
right whatever that number ends up being
those are the people that seem to be
affected the most uh obviously by
inflation because whatever money they do
have whether it's a lot or a little is
being uh eroded away over that long
period of time stable in the short term
but eroded over a long period of Time
how much of that do you think is really
what's getting at like wealth inequality
and some of these like longer term
trends that
um I would argue are very click baitable
you know kind of headline grabbing
things that people want to yell and
scream about they're real problems for
sure but there definitely seems to be a
disconnect between you know the data
points and yelling and screaming about
it versus like what's driving this stuff
and so is that one of the main drivers
is this like long-term devaluation of
the currency for a big portion of the
population yeah
I great question I don't think so
um I got two answers one is I think what
people really get concerned about in
inflationary environments is not so much
the level of inflation but the change so
we came out of a of an environment of
pretty low and stable inflation and then
suddenly it went up and that creates a
great deal of angst among people you're
worried you see the cost of living go up
rise very rapidly and you become worried
about whether your wages can keep up and
and this is this is The Angst that uh I
think uh it's not so much the level of
inflation it's the change you're worried
about whether you can keep up once
inflation settles into a range people
adapt and you see okay inflation was 10
this year yeah but I got a cola a cost
of living adjustment I mean I'm going to
get 10 so over long periods of time you
wouldn't be so concerned about uh
inflation for that reason
um a problem of course is high
inflations tend to be volatile inflation
so it's just one reason why we want low
inflation
what about savings I mean as you
mentioned most people aren't you know so
sophisticated that they're investing in
t-bills right now they're in Bank
deposits and I think last time I checked
even my my Bank of America account and I
think I'm getting zero percent I mean
I'm not very happy in fact I think I'm
going to start moving I don't like Banks
I said that in my 2014 talk by the ways
uh uh so um I said that half joking but
uh
so
in this case it's kind of interesting
right so this is now we're not talking
about
um sudden changes in inflation but just
inflation at some level say five ten
percent that whittles away the
purchasing power of zero interest
varying wealth which is as you mentioned
a large fraction of our our our of the
citizenry hold their wealth in this form
and doesn't that constitute a big tax on
their savings and isn't this what they
people complain about
I'd argue that that's right I mean
people do complain about that but we
can't miss the big picture here
one question is what's generating that
inflation
now if you take a look at the uh the
cares act the the American Rescue plan
these types of fiscal policies they're
very clear I mean for the most part
these policies uh transfer large
quantities of money to the bottom half
of the income distribution
I mean I didn't receive a check but a
lot of these people did receive checks
okay I mean that's partly what's
dragging the inflation apart from the
supply of shocks and the you know War so
uh
people at that end of the spectrum
should acknowledge perhaps that they are
net recipients of transfer uh income
that are partly responsible for
generating the inflation they get the
checks
they can go spend the money that drives
up the cost of goods for me too it's
just like me getting taxed I mean it's
part of my and probably your you know
we're losing purchasing power they're
losing purchasing power as well but at
least they're getting compensated
through the transfer system that's part
of our social contract in this country I
think people tend to not
look at that they look at the cost of
living but they don't think about yeah
well I think of income support they're
getting yeah I think a big part of it
too and again like you can spend numbers
a million different ways but um probably
the the most salacious view of this for
sure is like hey we gave people 1200 and
9 inflation like if you take a step back
and you do the math you don't have to
have that much in savings right to
realize like hey that's a bad end of the
trade yeah now I don't think that uh the
people who said let's give out 1200
checks yeah we're calculating and then
nine percent inflation and like we're
gonna you know we're gonna come out
better here right I don't think that
there was uh uh that sense I do think
that a lot of times the fiscal policies
um especially in moments of Crisis are
all about we have to do something right
and
um you know I I remember uh at the time
during uh kind of Q2 of 2020
I I think I either tweeted it or I wrote
kind of a longer piece I can't remember
basically being like you know there's a
a question at the moment of should we do
anything or should we do nothing right
so there's like a binary do something
don't do something and then if we choose
we should do something then there's a
whole bunch of you know options kind of
a buffet of options if you will that we
can pursue and at the time
I think I was more worried just about
like the do anything is almost
guaranteed to be an error right just
because it's nearly impossible how do
you walk up and you have you know 3 000
different options we're not going to get
it right
now looking back it's interesting that's
the same question right if we had done
nothing what would have happened now
we'll never actually know right
um
but I think it's very clear that the
impact especially on the on the monetary
policy side of cutting the interest
rates and things like that it served as
a great Catalyst that ended up taking us
from what was really a massive liquidity
crisis out of that pretty quickly yeah
and so how bad would that have gotten
would the free market have solved that
problem in a couple of weeks a couple
months a couple years we'll never know
but it is very obvious that the Federal
Reserve stepping in had this impact the
fiscal policies I think are harder
actually to underwrite because where the
funds went is uh sometimes very obvious
some people got a 1200 check some people
didn't there's Industries like the
airlines that kind of got these I think
they were called loans but eventually it
was just like oh you don't have to pay
this back type thing
um and the government didn't get equity
for it and kind of you know there was
this a a transfer of money without you
know kind of a reciprocal value uh given
back
um but then also it seemed like there
was whole bunch of money that got put
out and I don't think you know this but
at one point we literally live read
through some of these uh bills there was
crazy stuff in here right which every
political bill has it and I used to be
somebody who was like oh all the pork is
nonsense and you just gotta go and I
have a friend who I put in high regard
and he said it's the single most
important part of those bills and I said
what do you mean and he said well think
about this if you are in a position of
power and influence uh an elected
official for any period of time whether
it's you know one term or many and you
have to work with your colleagues in
order to get things done it is all about
finding some sort of middle ground and
so what ends up happening is the pork is
like the greasing of the wheels to get
some of this done but if it just came
down to one single issue he was like
you'll never get anything done because
you'll just constantly have uh these
battles and there's no room for anyone
to give and so I'm not 100 on board with
kind of his view of the world but I
think it now at least I understand more
of the trading that goes on and so when
you read through this stuff you're like
man we're you know one of the one one I
remember is the federal government was
essentially authorizing the purchase of
marijuana to test driving high right
scientific study we got to figure out
whatever
and I remember first of all immediate
reaction was like we have people in our
audience that will do that for free
[Laughter]
come by with government funds
um but but the second part was like
it's a very small part I mean like
literally non-material no one's even
talking about it yeah but if you add up
enough of these it becomes a material
part of the bill and net money is
inflationary and things like that and so
sitting inside of a central bank how
much is there worry or conversation
about the fiscal stuff versus just a
complete focus on the monetary policy
well uh that's that's great story I mean
politics is amazing you know I it's it's
you know I've read a lot about history
and and and these issues uh uh I I
always start to put things in
perspective first of all and go you know
look where we're sitting
look at this technology I love this air
conditioning
we do live in a pretty Civil Society you
know we there's 350 million of us all
very different it's kind of like Charles
de Gaulle when he said how how can you
expect me to govern a country with a
thousand different Jesus I mean it's
like we're actually you know let's all
step back and kind of be grateful
uh a little bit you know okay so now now
we can now now we can criticize okay so
monetary policy it's funny I I've got it
a little bit reverse from you I mean I'm
I'm
apart from uh the initial uh March 2020
fed intervention that kind of calmed the
financial markets and I have to say that
the FED really learned from the 08
crisis when a crisis hits I mean you
just forget you just go in there and you
do it I mean if there's this is one
thing we learned as you open up the fire
hose and indeed I wasn't aware of these
companies like Boeing for example
actually uh availing themselves of our
emergency lending facilities my
understanding is that just the
announcement that these facilities were
available calm down the corporate bond
marketing and that permitted Boeing to
actually erase funds privately for
example
um and so I thought that part of the FED
uh intervention was was very good I I
wasn't a big fan of the interest rate
cut to be quite honest
um why not
I I because I interest rate cuts are for
uh to stimulate aggregate demand and I
did not interpret the covet shock as an
deficient aggregate demand it was a
negative Supply shock this was a huge
sectoral shock where we actually asked
large portions of the uh economy just go
home stay home Leisure and Hospitality
got crushed for example and this was
part of the effort to slow the spread of
the pandemic if you recall kind of
flattened that curve now you're sending
uh you know a good sizable portion of of
your fellow Americans home and asking
them to for the sake of Public Health
it's Public Safety please stay home oh
and by the way you're not going to be
earning income and stuff you're not
going to be able to feed your families
are you crazy are you crazy I mean the
fiscal response the cares that was
absolutely the correct thing to do and
uh I think the counterfactual is well
known I mean in fact we we have a
counter factual just in the financial
crisis where where you know the banks
the financial system was largely quote
unquote bailed out and there's a broad
perception that uh the American
household was not I mean the American
household suffered to a great
foreclosure crisis in uh you know I mean
people were losing their homes and there
was a perception that there wasn't that
sense of urgency to help out the regular
American oh you're going to step in and
save the bankers who actually caused
this crisis but you're not going to help
the American homeowner and we saw what
this led to we saw the divisions in our
society that this led to the populist uh
uh politics we saw the damage that this
did and I think that this was the lesson
that was learned in 2020 that we're
going to go in and gosh it's going to be
ugly but we got it's better to get
somebody fed and there's going to be
some pork sloshed around I mean it's
going to be higher inflation but this is
not the time to quibble about it we can
worry later about re you know having a
contingency plan in place to deal with a
similar crisis that's bound to happen
again but you can't you don't ask these
questions when you're in the trenches
in March 2020 things look pretty scary
right
good question about what would have
happened without the intervention you
know um my goodness I mean uh yeah the
private the market always solves these
things right I mean how many people are
going to die how many people are going
to go hungry I don't know
it's a very difficult counterfactual I
think that by and large Joe I think that
the the government through the cares act
which I thought was brilliant I'm less
of a fan of the subsequent uh uh but uh
I think it was absolutely necessarily uh
to to do uh I I got to work from home
a lot of people didn't get the privilege
of working from home I think ideally uh
I would have been willing to be taxed to
transfer some purchasing power to those
that were uh affected adversely
disproportionately by the pandemic now
it so happened that the government chose
the inflation tax instead of a direct
tax but either way it was the right
thing to do and it was not just the
right thing to do but also it's a smart
thing to do politically and it's a it's
something that you know contributed to
the social stability I mean I I think we
if you hadn't done that we might have
people coming you know with with uh
pitchforks and torches
yes Eve well
sorry that was a bad example so
um I think that the the FED made a
mistake lowering interest rates
uh that the fiscal policy response was
uh you know to a first approximation uh
adequate uh or done correctly uh a lot
of ugly stuff in there as you allude to
perhaps they overdid it a little bit uh
the consequences are uh an elevated
inflation that by the way is starting to
come down so
um all in all we came out of this
you know this being the covid pandemic
and the subsequent War that's ongoing in
Russia Ukraine pretty well especially
relative to other countries and relative
to the hypothetical of what might have
transpired had uh the government not
supported the private sector I give
kudos to the private sector as well by
the way this is not just the government
this is this is us working together
private public sector we did a pretty
good job all things considered and it
was a terrible tragedy what happened but
so I want to take kind of that view of
the current events and let's go back to
your 2014 presentation
um and in it
uh you say two things uh pretty early on
in it you say Bitcoin hopes to one
achieve long-term price level stability
we've talked about and two Drive
transaction costs to zero and then you
follow that up with it is uh a stroke of
Genius a monetary system governed by a
computer algorithm now the reason why I
pull that out is because it's very
interesting to me it almost feels like
at the time you were like this is clever
you're not necessarily saying it's going
to replace all Fiat currencies in the
world and and you know kind of take over
and be the next Global Reserve currency
but I think that separating out hey this
is clever versus what is the impact on
the world and kind of the competition of
other currencies is important do most
Central Bankers understand that it's
clever do in conversations do they at
least acknowledge hey this Bitcoin thing
is actually pretty smart I don't think
it's going to be successful you know
competing with Fiat currencies or
whatever but just like that first point
do most of them get there or is there
still lacking in your conversations uh
of that at least uh kind of agreement I
mean in the early days uh that
recognition was completely absent I
would say yeah but I you know there
there are some very good researchers in
central banks around the world the bank
of international settlements that get
down in the nitty-gritty you don't hear
about them on the news they're just
nerds like me just working away and they
can appreciate kind of what's going on
yeah but at the time I mean you know
when I came to realize uh what was being
achieved which essentially to me the the
it was the solving the double spin
problem a problem for for digital money
systems basically without the use of a
delegated or trusted uh Record Keeper I
I thought it was I just went holy cow
this is like amazing uh first of all
um it turns out that uh there was
nothing individually in built into the
protocol that was unique but it was the
way in which uh it was combined to kind
of solve this problem and gosh I still
consider it to be a a stroke of Genius
uh and it's pretty cool and by the ways
uh it reminded me a lot of uh what we
talk about you know I think the reason
why I recognized in the genius because I
saw in it uh primitive versions of What
I Call primitive blockchain or primitive
consensus uh mechanism mechanisms in in
primitive economies like I I I think
this idea of a consensus you know a
keeping record of a community's history
for example through consensus is
something we do all the time in friend
networks and family and I I kind of
noticed that the spirit of the Endeavor
was was to go back to this uh a system
where record keeping was done just by
Word of Mouth in small communities
everybody knows what's going on in a
smaller Village there's no designated
Record Keeper you know and and so I
really I did appreciate uh what it had
accomplished and you're right uh whether
or not I thought that this was going to
replace the uh the dollar I I don't know
I I actually thought that it was uh a
step in the direction of moving uh
transactions cost to zero in terms of
moving money I I'm a little bit less
hopeful that they'll go zero because uh
it's in still an inherently very
difficult problem uh but that that was
the the hope I saw that that these uh
Endeavor was potentially going to help
solve so you also later on in the
presentation uh you're supposed to call
out a long tradition of new currencies
competing with old which I thought was
very interesting right that was almost
like a very bitcoiner thing to talk
about
um and you said probably the most
important aspect of this technology
Revolution is the threat of entry into
the money and payment system it will
force traditional institutions to adapt
or die and if you fast forward to 2023 I
mean that is almost dead on in terms of
what's happened right is
um you have central banks around the
world who some of them are like this is
absolutely nonsense these people are
idiots uh you have some countries now
very small number but some countries
saying well maybe we don't want to
replace dollars or anything but maybe
this actually does have some value and
and we'll start trying to figure it out
you have some public companies now
saying well maybe this is good for my
treasury again not a lot but a couple
and then you have estimates between 100
and 250 million people depending on who
you ask around the world who say hey
this deserves to have some portion of my
economic value right whether it's one
percent or 99.9 percent
but it is competition at the end of the
day and I would argue maybe it's as
close to free market competition as we
get because it's not warring centralized
institutions that kind of can conspire
or or Price fix or like you have one
that is fully decentralized enough this
free market asset
what is your kind of view at now having
seen you know nearly a decade of that
competition play out like it should we
have more competition or do we reach
some point where like there's too much
competition and hey everyone calm down
yeah I see the and You by it are you
referring to bitcoin specific Bitcoin
specifically yeah
um as opposed to more broadly yeah so
yeah uh more com I I view it more like a
darwinian competition it's unavoidable
uh and uh I am like many Americans uh
now actually I'm Canadian by birthstone
but I mean uh you know we we do need to
be aware of concentrations of power uh
concentrations of power uh they're
they're great for coordinating great
coordinating devices there's this
trade-off in my view we need the
fundamental problem of large economies
is how do we coordinate Behavior amongst
each other and it's useful to have these
Central nodes of these coordinating
mechanisms problem is that the power
becomes concentrated and uh and for this
reason I I thought you know the the
evolution of something like Bitcoin for
example I mean this is kind of good I
mean this is the threat of this it's
going to force some governments to kind
of perhaps you know if if certain
governments uh are abusing their power
of the inflation tax you know this is
different than just the US dollar now
any kid with a cell phone can download
an app and like start exchanging in
Bitcoin and it's going to be very hard
for the state to to kind of ban this
activity or enforce bans that this might
serve as a as a useful way to discipline
uh governments uh you know currency
competition I I still think that that's
the case and and as well also for our
our financial firms you know Bank of
America JP Morgan I mean all these big
institutions they have a lot of economic
power and and
um and you know it's uh I think that you
know the correspondent banking system is
kind of clunky and it doesn't seem to be
much I don't want to go too hard on on
the Global Financial system it has
evolved and improved relative to when I
was a kid
um so we we for all the kids out there I
I remember traveling to Italy with my
mom and having to go with Travelers
checks if you can believe that and and I
won't go into the details of how
difficult that was now I travel with a
credit card okay I guess I get ding fees
and sometimes it's tough to send money
to my friend and Cyprus or something
like that but um you know the evolution
of or the appearance of these uh
competing protocols I see as a useful
way to keep us on our toes I do think
it's useful and I do welcome it more
whether they can be too much of it I'm
not I'm not sure about that but some is
certainly good and healthy I think
is that a view that you see
uh popular inside the central banks or
is that a unique View and maybe
um one that uh colleagues whether at you
know us-based uh kind of Federal Reserve
and central banks or internationally may
not share well I'll be I'll be honest
with you I I think that uh probably most
people don't share this view in
governments and uh these institutions I
don't know what it is if they select for
people who are more inclined to kind of
apply the heavy hand of government or
whether a kind of mole of the culture
molds them in that direction I'm not
sure it's a very strong Instinct a lot
of us have by the way so myself yourself
probably too as you know we we're
Engineers we we like we like to think of
like solutions to problem and gosh if if
only people would listen to the way I
would design things you know it's an
instinct that's kind of you know a lot
of people
um but uh there are people that populate
these institutions that kind of have
similarities to me and I'll give you a
good example I mean uh we just had a
Federal Reserve Governor Chris Waller
come to the University of Miami to give
a talk on Central Bank digital
currencies uh and and the title of the
talk was uh demystifying Central Bank
digital currency now here we have a
Federal Reserve Governor uh appointed uh
um nominated by the last POTUS uh
ratified by Senate he's you know very
powerful position and he's saying like
what the heck since when since when does
the FED come in and since when is it in
the American tradition to have the
government compete with private firms
um I mean this is just not something we
do in America we don't say that the
government should create a car factory
to compete with General Motors and Ford
we don't do that uh you know we don't we
we we see the government as a partner as
a supporting agency to help support like
the FED supports the private Banks and
managing the payments it's there is a
lender of last support to regulate but
we don't actually necessarily want to
get into the business of handling retail
trades is that that's something that the
private sector does right uh very well
um and and so this is a high level fed
official expressing this view so if the
view is Not absent
by the ways I came up with a counter
example that the the U.S postal office
is actually uh in the Constitution
apparently but not that I'd set that up
as a model for Central Bank of course
but but that's uh to answer your
question shortly no I don't think the
view is kind of well appreciated or
popular but it is there yeah yeah
Central Bank digital currencies let's
talk about them
um scarce the hell out of me and many
other people uh when you start talking
about privacy
um one of the things that I use uh to
really highlight what I've perceive as
the dangers of them or
um you can have uh you know the the
surveillance State you can have the
whole social credit system that Everyone
likes to point and you know to China or
whatever but also even things that seem
maybe less uh um harmful but I think
still could be abused or things like
personalized monetary policy right if
all of a sudden I could say to one
person hey you're going to have a
currency that experiences low inflation
and somebody else is going to have one
that experiences High inflation and it's
based on your savings rate or on your
you know spending or consumption
patterns and again we've never had the
technology to do that but you know you
give that technology to someone it could
get kind of weird pretty quickly and I
think we always hope that people would
kind of use it for good and there's
probably a lot of reasons why you could
do positive things with it
there's a lot of bad stuff you could do
with it and so those are like the
negative side effects or the negative
possibilities the positive ones and I
think the first time that I ever saw
someone in the United States government
talk about a I think they called digital
dollar not such a big digital currency
but digital dollar uh was actually
during covid when it was uh introduced
in one of the early drafts as one of the
legislative bills and they basically
were saying like we need to be able to
you know deposit immediately the money
into someone's account so using this
digital dollar would allow us to do that
rather than sending checks blah blah
whatever
now interesting that it made it into the
first draft because there was no digital
dollar at the time and it wasn't
possible to be used uh but you can see
how people will come up with a Litany of
different use cases as to where it could
be helpful or beneficial
do the harmful kind of dangers outweigh
the positives or like how do you kind of
view these assets outside of the
government just usually hasn't done this
but if they did evaluate it like how do
you look at it yeah gosh great questions
you know well first of all uh Chris
Waller had Governor Waller's perspective
is he has a very nice uh a paper out
called uh um Central Bank digital
currency
a solution in search of a problem I
think it's called that and and so you
just mentioned one oh gosh this would be
nice we could send the digital money to
people during the pandemic well I mean
you can do that right now and have
everybody open up an IRS account or a
bank account I mean why can't you do it
through conventional payment rails you
know he he goes through the paper you
know Financial inclusion you know all
the Litany of things that a central bank
digital currency would allegedly solve
uh and he's we're already either already
being solved we have real-time payments
fed now uh the Clearing House is
real-time payments
um and and there's other ways to to
solve these problems rather the Central
Bank digital currency seems like a
pretty clumsy way to solve these
problems according to Governor Waller so
there's that
um in terms of but on the other hand in
terms of you you and many others are
afraid of the kind of the information
that might be available to the
government first of all keep in mind
that the FED would never do this
unilaterally it would only it it will
would only act uh with the authority of
Congress so it's Congress again you have
to go and and let your Congress your
representatives in Congress know how you
feel about this and get your feelings
expressed so if the fed's not going to
implement anything like this uh on its
own
um but if it were I mean how do you deal
with privacy issues well that's actually
you know it can be done I mean people
might not trust the solution but one one
one there's different versions of
Central Bank digital currency so one
version is what they call a synthetic
version where in fact uh you wouldn't
tell the difference between what your
regular bank account and a central bank
digital currency account you'd have an
account at the Bank of America and it
would be called your cbdc account and it
would be not a claim against Bank of
America the way your regular bank
deposit is it would be a direct claim
against the Fed
so a fully insured account with a uh the
Federal Reserve that's intermediated by
the Bank of America
Bank of America would be the one
observing your transactions the way they
do right now uh and so the the
government would not have in this
version of cbdc the type of information
that scares the heck out of a lot of
people is there an argument to be made
right now that a hundred percent of
deposits are insured by the US
government you know the FDIC is only
250.
uh it certainly seems that way uh that
that's uh I was hoping you weren't going
to get into this issue we can leave it
at that but it does beg this question
right of like um again maybe kind of
Waller is hinting towards this but some
of the things people are trying to do
like insurance or kind of who your
counterparty is to some extent
um in some way maybe we already have
part of this system in place even though
it's not explicitly said right and the
bank failures that we've watched over
the last you know couple of months
maybe it's actually highlighting the
system works a different way and and not
in a negative light actually for the
American citizen it works in a more
positive light because it means more of
their deposits are insured
um but it is different right than I
think kind of what the system was said
to do
yeah the the recent episode is kind of
strange in many ways like Silicon Valley
was very odd in many many ways there you
know their depositor their depositors
weren't you know I think they had 10
major depositors or something like that
not a very well Diversified depositor
base
um uh you know they took the hedges off
but they didn't follow a very prudent
acid management uh they took the hedges
off of their uh you know duration risk
uh they did a lot of things wrong one
thing that I heard is uh you know what
with these days especially with the lack
of diversification in the depositor base
was how rapidly the deposits uh
evaporated from these Banks uh from
Silicon Valley just the volume now
in principle that shouldn't be a problem
uh because uh if if Silicon Valley has
you know if they're being properly
regulated their assets are sound they
might be a liquid a little bit but
that's what the fed's discount window is
their expressly there to say Hey listen
people are panicking you have good
Securities will end you against this
good collateral my understanding was
that the deposit outflow was so large
that the discount window could not
handle the volume 100 but but that's
that's the the answer to that is to fix
that side of the window to make sure
that the window can can respond in in
the volumes necessary uh you know I
think the number uh I may get this wrong
so somebody will correct us for sure
um but I think the number was 40
something billion dollars was withdrawn
in the first day on that Thursday I
think that sounds right and I think even
more after that so I mean the volume was
incredible I mean look I wrote an entire
piece I called it a digital catastrophe
right it's basically actions in the
digital world that now benefit from the
speed of communication but also the
speed of action
um and the lack of friction to doing
some of this can have a very real
negative impact in in kind of reality
well I was I was thinking about this
question and the problem is not the
speed speed is great the problem is the
discrepancies in speed when systems are
communicating so here we got the speed
on the deposit editor side to withdraw
but the corresponding speed on the disk
The Landing side was not there you've
got the when the speed differentials are
different it's like you're going 100
miles down uh down a highway and
somebody's traveling at 20 miles an hour
that's the danger if everybody's going
100 miles an hour on the Auto Bond
that's not so problematic so I don't
think it's the speed per se as much as
it is the comparative speed yeah so we
we so in the evolution as we evolve I
mean thing you know we're not all coming
up to speed at the same rate that leaves
us vulnerable as it did in this last
crisis but I think that once you come up
to speed I think the high speed is not
going to be a problem yeah the other
piece of it that is um is fascinating to
me in that specific example is obviously
uh everyone's heard you know hey you
used to have to get down to the bank
stand in line you know you could talk to
people but you're pretty much talking
people who are right next to you right
and so uh information doesn't travel in
the same way
um Twitter obviously had a very material
impact here
um but somebody in the uh um in the
Bitcoin World a gentleman named Nick
Carter who may or may not know
um he pointed out that listen you know
some of the talk track of I think Janet
Yellen and a few others after basically
said look we've never accounted for the
speed of this happening and and kind of
the dissemination of the information and
all the stuff and his point was like
look computer's been around for a while
right you know his cell phone's been
around for a decade you know or 15 years
or whatever spent now and so
um he
he basically was like look again yes if
you've never seen it before it's hard to
kind of predict every individual Nuance
but to basically be like oh we never
thought about the fact that people can
withdraw online versus going in uh
standing in line it's hard right and and
then you get the emotion laid into and
all this stuff and so what are maybe
some other blind spots oh my goodness
that you're like you know this is
something that we maybe need to pay more
attention to or or
um uh maybe people aren't thinking about
they should be
well uh it's it's a great point you know
um it's to be fair I guess and I try to
be fair uh you know people uh like
yelling Powell they're fighting a lot of
fires I mean and and and they're human
and and the people working for them are
fighting fires uh and you're human you
you just have a limited bandwidth and in
retrospect when a crisis like this
happens you go though of course I mean
thanks Nick for pointing that out uh uh
where's your blog post kind of
highlighting this before the event uh
Nick if you're out there maybe he's
written that he's going to show us but
there's a 50 50 shot Nick wrote about it
before it happened if there's one person
that you may have actually written about
it and Nick would be the person well
I'll be impressed if he has and and and
and so we need to listen to people like
like Nick so um for myself my the blind
spots for me are
um are the inner well basically fighting
fires I mean it's like in the lack of of
formulating contingency plans going
forward so for example
I I forgave on our discussion about the
monetary and fiscal interventions during
covid I kind of forgave fiscal policy a
monetary policy for being crude and for
being not well targeted and there's some
pork and stuff like that but it's what
you got to do in a crisis it's better to
err on the side of caution I can forgive
you for that I mean
but I can't forgive you for us why
aren't we getting policies in place for
the next pandemic for the next Crisis
where where are the people sitting down
listen the next time this happens and
there's going to be a next time
how are we going to deal with it that's
I I think uh an example of of uh you
know that this is where I am most
critical of policy making is not not
that the actions are taken in the you
know in the in the trenches during the
war the battle but formulating the
strategy going forward for these types
of uh one-off events
um
yeah I I I I I don't know what to say I
try I do my part but it just seems like
uh people are so consumed with what's
happening right now that there doesn't
seem to be uh enough resources devoted
to these types of questions like where
are the weak spots what would we do uh
in the in the event this or this happens
I mean I I wrote a recent piece uh
actually in support of a central bank
digital currency for uh uh potentially
uh for an event for example that I think
policy makers should at least discuss
what is this event well the emergence of
these uh the centralized autonomous
organizations stable coins kind of like
the die
um less tether tether is not quite fully
dialed but I mean it's uh less regulated
but imagine something like a die like
object that uh or or some sort of
blockchain based Endeavor that kind of
permits firms in the global supply chain
to finance payments you know rather they
go through conventional American banking
system they go through this kind of
unregulated structure uh and it's going
to be very hard to regulate by
definition and and why might this be a
problem well I mean what a lot of tether
for example holds a lot of commercial
paper what if there's a run on Tether
and and there's a fire sale a commercial
paper is the Fed going to have to step
in is the Fed gonna have to like bail
out tether an unregular you know these
are questions
um maybe a cbdc that's available to
firms globally you know they can open
other accounts Finance their their
international trade and uh their
suppliers along the global supply chain
maybe offering a competing product might
be a way to discourage tether-like
objects from becoming too large and
becoming a systemic risk for example
very few people think like this I mean I
I don't know why I mean they're just uh
why why should I buy insurance
well I'm not going to need insurance I
mean fairness In fairness the general
public too does not think about these
things they're concerned Why is my why
are my eggs going up like them you know
it's inflation is the worry right now
and so you can see uh
um you know just policy makers are
really trying to fight the fire that's
kind of in front of them and I I think
that I wish that more effort would be
taken to thinking about these types of
events and you know maybe we should hire
uh Nick to come out and help us out Nick
it talks to enough Central Bankers where
I don't know if they like him or not but
he's talking
um one other thing around Central Bank
digital currencies that's kind of a
variation of it
um a couple years ago Mrs 2018 2019.
um I got very uh I felt like the curtain
got pulled back on a potential strategy
for corporations and it frankly worried
me right I said hold on a second here
I'm not a genius but I can put two and
two together and see how there's a path
to us getting into a world that we don't
want to be in right and so the idea was
um I think it was JP Morgan at the time
had come out and they had this JPM coin
and their thought process was we're not
going to offer it to retail we're only
going to offer it to our corporate kind
of Partners it'll be easier uh to move
money cheaper all all the things that
these uh promise
and they were going to back it with
dollars seems pretty reasonable right
hey it's basically just this digital
thing we're gonna move around it's
backed by dollars JPMorgan just for the
corporate Partners no retail okay
and I started thinking well if I was JP
Morgan and I was sitting there and I'm
not suggesting that Jamie Diamond is
thinking this way but if I was running
that bank uh and Jamie said hey be the
most evil person you possibly could be
well I would get my corporate Partners
to start using it then I would get my
retail customers to start using it and I
would get as much of the world using my
JPM coin as possible and then I'd wake
up one day and I would just unpeg it
from the dollar right somewhere to
coming off of the cold standard and now
I've got a money printer right and and
here we go and I can now use JPM coin uh
very similar to how Central Bank could
you know create and Destroy money
I'm not suggesting that that is what
they're trying to do or where we could
go but you could see any Bank
potentially getting into the situation
and so my point was like not really big
a big legislation guy but like we might
want to put some rules in place to
prevent people if you come out and you
say hey we got a coin uh or a stable
coin or whatever and it's gonna be
backed by something you can't later
change your mind and unpeg it right is
that a worry in terms of the central
banks not only competing with these
decentralized things but these private
companies creating their own currencies
um is that a worry I mean I'm sure you
can find uh you know a central bank is
populated by thousands of people so I'm
sure you'll find somebody who's worried
about stuff like that I'm not worried uh
why not
I
think it's wonderful if if I can move
money more efficiently with JP Morgan
that's great I mean I you know I I've
seen the advances in in payment
Technologies over the decades and most
of them have been private sector
initiatives if you take a look at m-pesa
project and sub-Saharan Africa take a
look at WeChat and alipay in China I
mean uh you know I mean the private
sector does provide these Solutions now
one of the fears though is is that you
know will a country lose its monetary
sovereignty uh I don't
no I don't think so I mean uh you know
first of all
how much
you you still in charge of regulating so
JP Morgan's still going to submit to
regulation okay and I and by the way
says there there's no way that they're
going to depeg J Morgan coin it's just
going to be a regular bank deposit I
mean are they going to suffer the
consequences of the charter revoke or
something but uh what about the fear of
a sovereign and probably maybe this is
more like I think a smaller country like
Canada I guess uh where I'm from you
know suppose people stop using the
Canadian dollar in Canada
as they start using the US dollar let's
say or JP Morgan coin or Bitcoin
I mean I don't know
um you know I can still imagine a
regulatory body that's kind of uh
governing the way Banks issue deposits
and there's still going to be
regulations about how their assets are
structured how their liabilities are
structured their Capital ratios
um at the end of the day well what about
monetary policy well I don't know you
still have fiscal policy how about a how
about a state contingent consumption tax
so you don't want to raise interest
rates raise the consumption tax that's
cool off economy you want to stimulate
the economy lower the consumption tax I
mean there's other mechanisms that one
might use instead what about the loss of
seniors the inflation tax yeah okay what
is that I mean how much do you derived
from that that's a very small fraction
of the total budget yeah you'd lose it
so what I mean uh uh replace it with
other taxes Life Will Go On what about a
country like El Salvador right so
obviously in the Bitcoin Community uh
there's a lot of people paying attention
to this experiment and now it appears
that maybe the IMF and others are also
paying attention because I've seen
reports that as they're issuing uh
various bailouts or kind of loans to
other countries they're saying hey you
can't do anything with crypto
um as a a kind of a clause in those
contracts but El Salvador is unique in
that it's dollarized right so they lost
their own currency I believe in a civil
war
um and when they use dollars dollars
seem to work right you and I go to the
ATM we could use dollar everything's
great they didn't replace the use of
dollars with Bitcoin they kind of just
said like well what about both yeah and
so they said we're going to keep dollars
as uh kind of a national currency
um and we're also going to add Bitcoin
and that's also going to be legal tender
here in our country
it's interesting right
um I think maybe the biggest benefit to
them so far has been tourism a lot of
people going to visit tourism has
exploded in the country right
um but how do you think about an
experiment like that where they're
basically trying to use both and and all
uh caveat this with I have a piece of
information the audience probably
doesn't have which is the second to last
slide in your 2014 uh presentation is
you basically uh I think the quote that
you used was a match made in heaven and
you have a picture of Janet Yellen and a
picture of a robot and Satoshi
nakamoto's name underneath it correct
and kind of this idea of like is that
actually maybe where we started the
conversation the dollar is a great
short-term uh kind of store value and a
use for as a medium of exchange and will
continue to be strong and then this idea
of Bitcoin maybe is like the long-term
solution that people can use yeah I
think there's there's that I guess in
that slide I was getting I actually had
like a ripple in mind at the time uh was
in my head because it was a currency
agnostic kind of uh payment rail is the
way I understood it at the time and uh
and one way to view this is uh is one
one service that Bitcoin is you know
what does what does Bitcoin offer that
people value I mean for me permission uh
permissionless access and use
it offers
um
you know a hard money policy and a
pretty cheap uh payment rail hopefully
cheap
and so uh you know to the extent that in
a country like El Salvador people have
difficulty for one reason or the other
say the banking system is not well
developed the people are not well
connected to the banking system there's
many unbanked that gosh you know uh why
not uh uh except Bitcoin is as legal
tender means that the government will
find it perfectly acceptable for you to
pay your taxes in Bitcoin gosh I don't
know why people in the Bitcoin Community
get excited about paying taxes I've
never seen uh such excitement over
paying taxes in that Community but
that's what it means at the same time
there's the payment rail I mean it's a
wonderful thing you know not now that
the Central Bank the government doesn't
really have to go through the effort of
trying to build the payment rail you
know there's a lot of effort involved
the you know because uh a money and
payment system is essentially a database
management system you have to worry
about Communications keeping
communication secure keeping making sure
the accounts are kept safe Bitcoin
solves all these problems why not let
people Avail themselves of this uh
payment rail if it serves that purpose
and at the same time you can have the
domestic legal tender in the uh is it I
don't think the US dollar is legal
tender there is it don't they have the
it is yeah so
um my understanding again I could be
wrong is uh they lost the currency uh
during a Civil War and so they adopted
the dollar dollar uh has great benefit
but it's hard it's dangerous I'm a big
believer in coexistence and uh because
it's it's actually characteristic of
History by the way says I've mentioned
there's been a long history of local
currencies coexisting with a dominant uh
uh you know National currency uh even in
the United States and paper form I mean
the uh
the Ithaca hour for example in Cornell
uh is uh at Cornell there Ithaca New
York is a famous example
um and so yeah why not why not try this
experiment see if it works I'm not sure
how well it's working right now by the
ways but I mean
what's what's what's the harm I mean uh
I I think I'm I'm happy as a as a social
scientist I'm very excited to see this
but uh well it would it really in some
degree it's like um it goes back maybe
to the soros's view of the world of like
uh Bitcoin success or failure uh is
something that many people evaluate as
Bitcoin success or failure but by El
Salvador adopting it they are betting on
the success of Bitcoin being the first
country to publicly adopt it has an
impact on the success of Bitcoin right
you get into this kind of circular world
where maybe actually if there are people
who want to see the success of it the
thing that they can do is to adopt it
because it helps drive for the success
now the risk with that is the reflexive
nature of everyone keeps doing that and
you risk you know against Soros with the
bust side of the boom bust cycle
um but again it appears that you know at
least that one country and again small
country but that one country does see
this as a viable option I think so and
uh yeah I like that Solo's take on it um
the other thing I like is I like I like
to see redundancy as well I mean I don't
see why we have to rely on one single
system I mean if it goes down you you
would like to Avail yourself to the
other so you can imagine people holding
a Bitcoin account a U.S dollar account a
year but why not you might lose a little
bit in terms of efficiency but you gain
in in robustness and by the ways I just
want to point out that even if Bitcoin
were to fail in in a narrow sense of
let's say the token goes to zero nobody
uses a protocol I would still say
Bitcoin has been a success for the
inspiration that it's uh instilled out
there there's many many uh projects out
there that I would call that are not
strictly speaking they don't use proof
of work they don't use the exact type of
Bitcoin protocol but they've motivated
many many people to think kind of
outside the box and I call them Bitcoin
inspired projects so I think Bitcoin has
been a success will be a success kind of
irrespective of what ultimately happens
to the value of its underlying token or
use there's a great Point
um so we talk about El Salvador as I was
sitting here thinking I'll say wait a
minute they're using dollars and they're
using Bitcoin well I know another
country that uses Dollars around the
United States is there a world where you
think the U.S should make Bitcoin legal
tender and say it's not a replacement
but it's a you know a both situation
it's dollars and Bitcoin yeah
um
you know there is a branch in the
economics literature that you know
recognizes the role of the US Dollars
the global Reserve currency and sees it
as kind of a net negative for America
like this can be too much of it
um and it's it's we we do benefit from
the seniors we extract from the rest of
the world but uh there's this thing
called The triffin Dilemma yeah you can
you can uh Google that as well it's kind
of a double-edged sword and some
economists like Michael Pettis in
particular have argued that it's led to
a Halloween out of uh it requires us to
run current account deficits which
basically which basically means
you're going to lay off all the uh
manufacturing workers here let them fend
for themselves and import let China
manufacture all the goods and by the
ways is that really a good idea uh and
so
should we kind of encourage D
dollarization for example by permitting
uh say Bitcoin to be a a legal Tanger
kind of encouraging the use of some
alternative currency
um
The Advocates of the side where there's
too much dollarization might be in favor
of of something like that uh although to
be honest I don't see this ever
happening anytime soon but one could see
the logic of it uh yeah so I wasn't
planning to do this but now I'm
interested in uh in your thoughts um I
want to paint a picture of a potential
path I'm not saying this is the path
that I even would bet on but I think
it's an interesting thought exercise
um my view of the world is that the
single best place to be as a country is
to be the owner producer and controller
of the global Reserve currency for a
whole bunch of reasons there's downsides
that you know as you just mentioned but
I think most countries aspire to have uh
that control
the second best place is to use a
currency for the rest of the world that
no one controls
right like if you're not in control you
kind of don't want anyone else to be in
control is is maybe a a very generalized
framework
now in that world if the United States
actually does suffer from kind of global
dollarization and there would be this
argument for D dollarization
um other countries around the world if
everyone began to use a currency that
was separated from any nation state so
you know use Bitcoin as the example but
but uh could be a whole host of things
people could create but let's use
Bitcoin
in that world does it actually create
one less violence because now you're not
fighting over uh using currencies in in
these kind of violent interactions
um but two is do you now actually
similar to uh GMT time right where the
entire world can look at one time system
and use it regardless of geography Etc
do you start to standardize across the
world and now you essentially would
replace the foreign currency markets now
I don't actually think in this scenario
they go away it kind of would be like
the Euro and maybe some of the
underlying currencies right
but it's an interesting way to look at
like is there a world where actually
it's a net positive to every country to
adopt a global Reserve currency that is
not tied to a nation state what do you
think about that
I can see the Merit of that argument
right I think that um the special
drawing right the IMF special drawing
rate would be an example of that uh
potentially as well
um
and again uh you know there's the issue
of coordinating on a when I write down
my economic models it says one currency
please
that's the most efficient thing uh
Robert Mundell the Canadian Economist
who won the Nobel Prize for his work in
part on optimal currency areas kind of
explains their circumstances where you
might not want just one but a few
um but
you know the you can kind of see the
mirror it's kind of like having a
consistent yardstick the idea just as
now the second uh thing is how do you
govern this currency how are the
payments process is going to be Bitcoin
for example or we could imagine a
Bitcoin inspired protocol if it doesn't
isn't quite as hard as the monetary
policy yeah it potentially uh
be net beneficial
um
whether or not it would lead to Greater
peace I mean uh I don't know Tony I
think you have a much uh more optimistic
uh Viewpoint than I do I think we'd find
different things to fight about and we'd
find uh you know I've often railed
against uh bitcoiners who uh kind of uh
you know believed or expressed a belief
that you know uh that strangling the
state of this uh of this uh this source
of seniors and inflation tax would lead
to peace I go no it's just going to make
them build tanks and come after you
physically and take your property
physically it's actually it might even
promote violence so it's not entirely
clear I think that we should focus more
on kind of you know a governing
ourselves in a more sober and kind of
adult-like manner
um and and then you know this type of uh
Vision that you have I can see the
merits of that actually I mean I could
see how that could work
um and why not have it as part of uh you
know I mean I have an option imagine you
and I have an option of when we do have
this option and I imagine say big coin
for example does become very popular
suppose uh as a global a medium of
exchange sure why not I still probably
want to hold a US dollar based account
as well I don't see the United States uh
not letting US Dollars be legal tenders
I would still pay my taxes and U.S
dollars I'll still pay the Canadian
government in you in Canadian government
dollars so there's always going to be a
a demand for for these different
currencies that's conserve the needs of
the different constituents again I'm a
big believer in coexistence if this
vision of yours was to actually
transpire I I think it would be a good
thing actually but I don't think it
would end violence well I I think the
violence component is one area for sure
where I think Bitcoin rising in
popularity even to Global Reserve status
every Global Reserve status change that
we have seen has been at the hands of
some violent weapon right used to be uh
bows and arrows and eventually uh now
with the United States military uh uh
doing it but
in a weird way
Fiat currencies and the changing regimes
has always been about who had the
greatest offense you went to some other
land and you were able to uh basically
take over right and and you had military
Victory on their land and therefore now
you are the dominant military and so you
get to put the global Reserve currency
in place
in the cyber world it's not all about
offense it's actually about defense and
so in that way my thought process has
always been and
I'm actively looking to have it
disproven right like this is something
where it's like man this is interesting
but I don't think we have enough time to
to really kind of yes or know it
if defense is the most important thing
actually the strongest defense will then
lead to the global Reserve currency and
nothing is more defendable or
decentralized or stronger than the
Bitcoin Network and so could it be the
first Global Reserve currency that rises
to that status without ever shooting a
bullet dropping a bomb you know creating
any sense of violence that doesn't stop
violence from you know Russia Ukraine I
don't think is necessarily happening
right now over uh Global Reserve status
of a currency so not all violence goes
away but in some way a global Reserve
currency being established with no
violence is like fascinating to me I see
yeah
um I'm trying to think of counter
examples to that statement this is why I
like talking to you because I knew
that's what you were thinking I I don't
my my knowledge of History isn't that
great about it but I know that you know
uh I think that
um in recent memory I mean we've had
three Global Reserve things as operated
like Global Reserve currencies dominant
Global currencies at the most recent
being the US dollar uh and prior to that
it was the British pound and and prior
to that my understanding it was the uh
the Dutch curse of the Netherlands had
uh the Netherlands of course was a
tremendous economic power I think in the
17th century if I historians out there
can correct me on that Century
um uh the uh the Dutch where I as far as
I know were not I don't think I guess
they did colonize here or there but they
weren't a mighty Global power but they
were a mighty commercial power
uh and so I don't know if that's a kind
of a counter example my point is is that
these these two things seem hard to
separate it's true
that the British Empire was the most
powerful militarily but they're also the
most powerful economically
uh likewise it's the same is true the
United States
um
but I wonder I wonder if those two
things are necessarily wedded maybe so
uh I'd have to think about it but you're
you're Insight here about defense being
so attractive in that uh you know
there's no there's no elected leader of
Bitcoin there's nobody who's gonna go
out and fight
and and use Bitcoin uh the power of
Bitcoin seniors to finance Global uh
Conquest uh that this is just a protocol
just by its sheer a design and the
properties in its design is going to
attract people and that's going to be
become powerful precisely because it's
it's it's very peaceful in fact it's
agnostic and it's just a robot
that would be very interesting uh to see
that
emerge for that reason
do you think that was this is a
reasonable shot of happening and if so
what would be your timeline for
something like this timeline is
impossible we might not be around to see
it but who knows who knows what might
happen I mean I think that
um
my memory will fail me here but I think
it was 2017 or 2018 there was a couple
of countries for some reason I want to
say like Argentina and name whatever
other country that decided to do some
test settlement of bilateral trade in
Bitcoin now before everyone gets excited
this was like ten thousand dollars right
this this was like literally didn't even
matter for either country
um but just the fact that they were even
willing to try it announce it Etc was
interesting to me
UCL Salvador obviously doing this
um we haven't talked about Mining and
kind of uh some of these very oil-rich
countries that may actually use it as uh
some ability to monetize some of that
energy in a much more cost effective way
one of the uh kind of negative sides of
some of this is I had a a gentleman from
the economics Department of Harvard who
was saying look Bitcoin after the
sanctions on Russia now enters the
conversation as a sanctions Hedge for
many countries
um along those same lines there's a
report I will say it's unconfirmed
because I haven't been able to find the
exact Source material but it was pretty
Popular by a number of people I trust on
Twitter uh that there has been an
explosion of Asic uh kind of Bitcoin
mining Hardware orders inside of Russia
and so if you basically you sanction
them off you don't let them really kind
of engage in the energy markets they
have Surplus energy
they want to monetize it well one great
way to do it may be through an
apolitical you know kind of uh monetary
system where they can literally monetize
it at the point of the energy production
you know you kind of start seeing some
of these data points and you're like
look again
it is nearly impossible to predict the
future in fact I would argue it is
impossible to predict the future but
there's enough data points that suggest
uh countries will more countries are
going to embrace this in the future than
less and so if that is the path
well maybe actually Bitcoin is the first
technology of our lifetime that's been
globally adopted by individuals before
nation states right if you think of most
Technologies whether it's internet
computers whatever it's like the
military the nation states then
corporations then finally someone got
the you know the uh PC to be on
everyone's desktop right and they got
the costs down and all the stuff
there's like no Nation today right I
mean literally you're the first Central
Banker in the world that I think either
you or I know of to do a public
presentation on Bitcoin in 2014. it was
five years of individuals around the
world running around trying to figure
out what this thing was and frankly some
of them got it right some of them you
know there's the classic tweets that go
viral all the time where the guy's like
so glad I sold my Bitcoin at three
dollars
right it's now 50 cents
um so you know this stuff's hard even if
you're early
but it does kind of point to this world
of like Bitcoin will become in my
opinion more important in the future
what does that mean in terms of the
day-to-day usage I have no clue right
and I think that's maybe where I differ
from some folks in the Bitcoin Community
is I think they are adamant about you
know 100 it is going to be the global
Reserve currency I'm probably in the
camp of like there's a higher
probability I would assign to it than
many other people I know in finance or
technology
but I don't know if I would be
comfortable saying 100 right I don't
know what do you think
I mean I would never say never first of
all uh and I don't think it's likely
within my lifetime which admitted these
not that long for you youngsters out
there but but uh
you know you'd have to ask the question
um
you know first of all I think it's
ironic that uh the the ability of Russia
to Avail of itself of this is not
exactly something I'd call to promoting
peace but anyways uh
you'd have to think you know
um
about certain countries about their
political institutions how they're set
up and the propensity of the local uh of
of the uh Representatives or tyrants in
some case of their propensity to uh
permit their citizens to redo to to
utilize this technology oh but how are
you going to prevent it uh I mean you
just access it through the internet and
blah blah blah well and and they can't
appropriate it either right not not
directly well I'm afraid you know if
you've got a deaf spot uh I mean I I
think can take some pretty pretty
dramatic measures I mean they they won't
know your private key but you know
they'll they'll they'll take your
daughter and string her up on a tree and
then you you'll have a choice you can
submit your private key or not it's true
uh you know so I don't know uh whether
you know for these reasons I mean these
these base human instincts or these
these these jurisdictions where you you
get these governments that are just
tyrants
uh are probably not gonna
permit Bitcoin to become Universal in
the sense that perhaps some people hope
and even if it did become Universal like
I said it's a Bitcoin will not solve the
problem of uh despotism or tyranny but
who knows I mean I can I see the
argument that you're making and I and I
share with you I I think it's going
to spread and and if and indeed like I
said even alluded to earlier even if
Bitcoin itself doesn't spread but I do
believe it will spread I think the
adoption is still relatively early uh
that Bitcoin inspired projects will will
spread as well so I
Bitcoin itself I don't know let's see
let's see if these Bitcoin masks these
turn out to be right the last thing I
want to talk to you about is the
University of Miami so uh you and I met
sometimes it was friendly sometimes we
were debating ferociously uh all sorts
of different things on Twitter yeah and
then one day you messaged me and you
said by the way I am coming to the
economics department at University of
Miami yeah just right down the road and
I was like oh it's amazing
um and talk about why why take that job
and what are you trying to do with the
the economics Department there yeah yeah
so you know I I'm a a life uh long
academic uh have Italian Roots just like
yourself that we talked about that over
coffee uh yeah I made my way uh from
pretty humble beginnings uh to to you
know I lost my job during the 1981-82 my
construction sector job between the 1980
182 recession that Paul volcker
engineered and and that made me go back
to school to kind of discover uh what
what was that all about and and I've
made my way through the Canadian uh
academic system as a professor of
economics in Canada for about 20 years
and then I made my way to the FED in
2009 during that crisis very exciting uh
to to be there to consult and to
experience uh what was happening there I
got to meet Paul volcker by the way and
let him know that he was responsible for
me being there thank you very much uh
um but you know I had a very good run at
the FED I met some great people it just
it's it's you know I my respect for the
institution I mean it has its flaws
don't get me wrong I've been very
critical of of the FED as well I think
it's important for all you out there to
criticize the FED for the right reasons
not the wrong reasons uh and I had a
great run 13 years
but
I learned a lot uh being a you know a
policy advisor at the at the highest
level at the FED I was a lifelong
academic and I thought that for for my
final Act what I'd like to do is to come
back to University my first love and to
transmit to the new generations kind of
the accumulation of knowledge that I I
have both uh through the literature and
my experiences at the fed and I I really
wanted to have an opportunity to to
teach the Next Generation what I what I
learned into to and this is and so when
the opportunity in Miami came up uh you
know I I leapt at it and uh I I came as
chair of the economics Department which
is located in the Miami Herbert business
school the University of Miami and and
we're trying to build a department
that's uh relevant policy relevant that
we have top researchers that contribute
to the literature but that also are re
based in reality that are interested in
contemporaneous policy issues we we just
sponsored that talk by Federal Reserve
government governor Chris Waller on a
very topical issue Central Bank digital
currency these are the types of events
we want to sponsor was free to the
public the comma meet the government
governor and ask questions we are uh
growing we are recruiting and we were
thinking of reconstituting our master's
program which I think went defunct after
a few a few years ago and we're thinking
about how to model that we're thinking
about what needs there are in the defy
community in particular we have a
fabulous Department of business
technology in the business school we
have a fabulous Business Law Department
we're thinking Defy is a space where
economics law and Technology kind of
naturally intersect what type of courses
might we offer to students
um we recently I recently talked to uh
one of the chief economists at Amazon by
the way see he noted to me that Amazon a
few years back came to the realization
that they needed some macro economists
that the the global factors are kind of
ninety percent of what matters does and
Amazon now that they're big Global uh
economy or a company and so we're
thinking how can we tailor this this
master's program in a way that serves
the students needs and the needs of the
community Miami which we are very
bullish on we think Miami is just
especially the D5 Community the area
you're in uh so I'd love to have
feedback I'd love to meet people to
discuss ideas uh if you have ideas for
internships collaborations
talks if you'd like me to come and give
a public lecture or whatever I'd be very
happy to do so and to develop a
relationship with you we'll put you on
the podcast Circuit of Miami
[Laughter]
um my last question for you is you've
been doing this a long time now what is
your single best memory at the
intersection of your work economics
Finance markets Etc like you've met all
these amazing people you've had all
these moments like if you could point
back to one thing that you're like man
that was fun what would it be oh gosh
there were so many uh
um I remember I don't know one one
memory stands out actually I remember uh
my colleague Jane Erick and I working on
uh in in I think was early 2019 uh
recommending that the FED adopt a
standing repo facility that it would
help uh for a variety of reasons and and
and we wrote that article to There Was
You Know completely ignored uh and in
the fall of that the year
um uh that we have this many repo
tantrum and I was in a in a vehicle
actually going to an fomc meeting I was
a uh
um there was um Jim Bullard myself I was
accompanying Jim Bullard and I think uh
Neil Kashkari and Mark Wright and as
we're heading to the FOC meeting uh the
news of this event uh transpired and uh
kashikari turns to me in the back says
geez we should have adopted your
standing rainbow facility
that was satisfied in there
yes that's why I wrote the article it
did the work and I remember Jay Powell
came to the this his family you know and
he said oh I'm going to be at the FED uh
we should meet up and uh and he gave a
talk there were about 60 people there
and and uh at the talk and I I never
went to seek him out uh but uh you know
he's there's a big ball of people around
him and I just was in the corner um yeah
with my my wife there talking and then
uh uh
the chair Powell comes up and said oh
David he goes oh and he shakes my hand I
just wanted to let you know that I I
really appreciate your work on this any
repo facility I think you're just doing
it fantastic yeah you know that's very
gratifying for him to he's a super nice
guy by the way I mean he didn't have to
do that and he went out of his way to to
and I think by the way that's as
important lesson for all of us to kind
of acknowledge the people who are
working with us to let them know when
they've done a good job so these are
that's a couple of highlights for me
that's amazing yeah yeah it's fun the um
uh riding in the car with uh with those
guys must have been uh must have been a
blast I always wonder uh do you just sit
and talk about Economic Policy the whole
time or do they talk about other things
and it's not just about Economic Policy
you'd be surprised to learn that uh you
know we're a fun group of people as well
we have a wide variety of interests it's
not just economics we are we are econ
Geeks as well but uh we we do talk about
other things what do they say make
economics fun again exactly that's our
motto All right listen thank you so much
for taking the time to do this uh where
can we send people to either find you on
the internet or find out more about
yesterday at University of Miami well
thanks a lot Tony this is a lot of fun
listen you can you know I'm out there
like you just Googled my name you're
gonna it's gonna come out that's the
easiest thing but I'm at the University
of Miami Miami Herbert Business School
uh and if you just Google my name I
think is the easiest way
awesome and you are a fantastic follow
on Twitter it's a it's a good dose of uh
hey wait a minute maybe we should like
think twice before we tweet some of the
stuff that uh well I love following you
as well you're a great source of ideas
and it's just a lot of fun that I'm so
glad we got to meet in person absolutely
all right well thank you so much we'll
do it again in the future thank you